digamos que tenemos una matriz que tiene
todas sus entradas debajo de la diagonal
iguales a cero aunque hay por ejemplo
bueno empecemos con una matriz de dos
por dos para que quede todo clarísimo
entonces digamos que tenemos la matriz a
que va a ser una matriz de 2 por 2 donde
todas sus entradas debajo de la diagonal
son 0 así es que en la primera entrada
tenemos a en la segunda tenemos a b
después aquí en lugar de tener hace ya
sabemos que las es igual a 0 entonces
ponemos un 0 y después tenemos aquí un d
entonces nos queremos preguntar cuál es
el determinante de esta matriz ok
entonces tenemos que el determinante de
a es igual pues esta es una matriz de
dos por dos cualquiera entonces su
determinante es a por de menos a ver a
por de menos b por 0 pero eso tal cual
es un 0 de hecho ni siquiera lo tenemos
que escribir así es que vamos a borrarlo
y entonces si tenemos una matriz de 2
por 2 tal que debajo de la diagonal
principal
esta es la diagonal principal tenemos
que todas las entradas son iguales a 0
entonces al menos en el caso de 2 por 2
el determinante es igual a multiplicar
las dos entradas de la diagonal ok ahora
vamos con otra matriz ahora con una
matriz de 3 por 3 tenemos aquí a b que
va a ser una matriz de 3 x 3
que tenga todas sus entradas debajo de
la diagonal iguales a 0
ok entonces tenemos aquí a d
después tenemos un cero
y aquí tenemos de
y tenemos aquí un 0 y otro 0 y aquí
finalmente una f aunque entonces esta es
la diagonal principal y todas las
entradas debajo de la diagonal principal
son iguales a cero entonces cuál será el
determinante de esta matriz de tres por
tres hace algunos vídeos vimos que
podíamos tomar el determinante sacarlo a
lo largo de cualquier fila o cualquier
columna cierto ya lo que hacíamos era
escoger una columna y calcular el signo
de cada una de las entradas y
multiplicarlo por la sub matriz 1
multiplicando por la entrada
correspondiente y luego por el
determinante de la sub matriz que nos
queda de quitar la columna que contiene
esa entrada y la fila que contiene de
centrada cierto bueno entonces vamos a
hacer lo mismo que hemos estado haciendo
en todos estos vídeos que es tomar la
fila que más nos convenga en este caso
aquí en esta columna hay dos ceros y eso
va a hacer que sea mucho más fácil sacar
el determinante de b utilizando ésta
ok entonces sacamos el determinante de b
y lo que hacemos es calcular el signo de
la entrada 11 menos 1 elevado a la 1 más
1 que en este caso es 2 entonces menos 1
al cuadrado nos queda un 1 así es que
podemos borrar este signo
y luego tomamos la entrada que en este
caso es a por el determinante de la sub
matriz que nos queda de quitar la
columna y la fila o sea de cero efe
efe y entonces vamos con el siguiente
determinante que nos toca entonces
tenemos aquí un mes aquí nos toca un
menos 0 0 por el determinante de la sub
matriz que nos queda de quitar la fila y
la columna de abc 0 f
pero efe y finalmente aquí tenemos un
menos nos toque aún más la entrada que
es 0 0 por el determinante de la sub
matriz que nos queda de quitar la fila y
la columna correspondientes entonces nos
queda de ese de
b c d ok entonces vamos a hacer todas
las cuentas aquí nos queda a x
y de este determinante es igualito este
determinante nada pero bueno el chiste
es que nos queda de por efe de por efe y
luego tenemos que multiplicar a la x
menos por 0 pero es por cero por cero
entonces ni siquiera lo tenemos que
poner aquí entonces el determinante debe
tal cual es
a por de por f por qué pues porque estos
dos determinantes están multiplicando a
un 0 entonces este es un 0 y este
también es un 0 entonces aquí tendríamos
que sumar un 0 que ni siquiera vamos a
poner así es que aquí tenemos una matriz
de 3 por 3 tal que debajo de su diagonal
principal que es ésta
tenemos puras entradas que son iguales a
0 y su determinante resultó ser a por d
por efe
o sea tal cual multiplicar cada una de
las entradas de la diagonal principal
esta es la diagonal principal
y está muy curioso porque lo mismo pasó
para el caso de matrices de 2 x 2 aunque
ya aquí tenemos nuestra matriz de 2 por
2 general debajo de la diagonal
principal que esta es la diagonal
principal todas las entradas son iguales
a 0 si sacamos su determinante entonces
su determinante resultó ser la
multiplicación de las entradas que están
en la diagonal principal entonces
seguramente te estás preguntando sucede
lo mismo pero para cualquier matriz de
cualquier tamaño que tenga puros ceros
debajo de la diagonal y si estás
pensando eso estás en lo correcto sin
embargo siempre que queremos hacer una
afirmación tan general tenemos que
demostrarlo así es que vamos a empezar
por
escribir nuestra matriz vamos a llamarle
otra vez
nuestra matriz de n por n
aquí tenemos un a1 aunque vamos a
escribir una matriz de n por n n por n
que tenga puras entradas iguales a 0
debajo de la diagonal ok y aquí se ve
muy claro cuál es la diagonal porque
justo las entradas que están en la
diagonal son las que tienen sus
subíndices iguales o sea el a1 1 está en
la diagonal principal el 22 también está
en la diagonal principal al igual que el
33 y así nos seguimos hasta llegar al a
n n y entonces nosotros queremos que
esta matriz debajo de esta diagonal
principal tenga puros ceros
así es que aquí tiene que haber un 0 0 0
y aquí pues 000 blah blah hasta la
penúltima entrada que cero y por acá
también tienen que haber puros ceros y
por aquí pues por aquí puede estar
cualquier entrada que se nos ocurra y
para denotar a esas entradas que son las
que se nos ocurra siempre ponemos ahí
nuestro ah1n1 2
y asigna entonces esta es nuestra matriz
diagonal superior así les llamamos a las
matrices que tienen puros ceros debajo
de la diagonal cree entonces a este tipo
de matrices que tienen todas sus
entradas debajo de la diagonal principal
igual y tasa cero les llamamos matrices
o matrix matriz triangular 3
superior
pero lloré porque como que parece un
triángulo no sé aquí todas estas
entradas son iguales a cero y todas
estas pues algunos pueden ser iguales a
cero pero todavía no sabemos y pues el
triángulo que tal vez es distinto de
cero está como que por encima de la
diagonal entonces por eso son matrices
triangulares superior pero bueno
calculemos el determinante de esta
matriz y el determinante de la matriz a
al igual que en esta matriz pues nos
conviene tomar una columna que tenga
muchos ceros no entonces lo que vamos a
hacer es escoger esta columna y sacar el
determinante de a a lo largo de esta
columna así es que empezamos tenemos
esta primera entrada que tiene el signo
positivo a 11 por el determinante de la
sub matriz que nos queda cuando
eliminamos la fila y la columna que
contiene a 1
y entonces nos queda a 22 y nos queda
toda esta sub matriz dentro del
determinante entonces aquí nos queda a
22 hasta a 2 n equipu los ceros aquí a
n por aquí m m y por aquí nos quedan
puros ceros
creo que esta no es una buena forma de
dibujarlo
que aquí tenemos un triángulo de 0 2 0
final 0 inicial y muchos puntitos en
medio y entonces vamos con la siguiente
entrada pero resulta que la siguiente
entrada es un 0 10 por su sub matriz
correspondiente que pues no importa
porque la vamos a multiplicar por un 0 y
ya y lo mismo pasa para el resto de
estas entradas de la columna así es que
podemos simplemente borrar nuestro cero
y entonces lo único que tenemos que
hacer es calcular este otro determinante
y multiplicarlo por a 11 pero resulta
que este otro determinante es muy
parecido a este determinante que
estábamos sacando no o sea sigue siendo
una matriz triangular superior nada más
que ahora en lugar de ser el
determinante una matriz de n n estã sub
matriz es una matriz de n menos 1 por n
menos 1 lo cual tiene todo el sentido
del mundo por cómo definimos el
determinante entonces este nuevo
determinante también es una matriz de
angular superior y entonces pues le
vamos a aplicar
exactamente lo mismo no
aquí nosotros ahora vamos a calcular el
determinante de esta matriz y entonces
lo que hacemos es escoger esta fila
ya que tiene la entrada a 22 y puros
ceros en el resto de la columna y
entonces este determinante es
exactamente igual a 11 que ya lo
teníamos
por ahora escogemos esta entrada que es
a 22 por el determinante de otras sub
matriz pero que ahora empieza en 33
porque eliminamos esta fila y esta
columna
entonces se va así hasta a3n y aquí
tenemos a nuestro triángulo de ceros
y aquí tenemos a un emmy y por acá el
resto de las entradas y después tenemos
que sumar por 0 por el determinante
quitar estas cosas pero eso es igual a
cero para todas estas entradas ya se ve
muy bien el patrón no entonces lo que
estamos haciendo es quitar la fila de
hasta arriba y la columna de la
izquierda y en cada interacción del
proceso lo único que nos aporta es la
entrada de la esquina superior izquierda
así es que después de mucho tiempo de
hacer esto lo que vamos a obtener es a
11 que ya lo teníamos por a 22 por 33
quitamos la fila quitamos la columna nos
queda a 44 quitamos otra fila y otra
columna y entonces nos queda en la
esquina superior izquierda a 55 y así un
montón de veces hasta que llegamos
en m2 en m2 por el determinante de una
sub matriz muy particular o sea ya lo
único que nos va a quedar son estas
últimas cuatro entradas y estas últimas
cuatro entradas es pues aquí un cero
porque aquí tenemos nuestros 02 estamos
tomando este cuadradito aquí
en n ii y n 1 n menos uno y por aquí nos
va a quedar a n menos 1 m creo que
tampoco fue a la letra verdad pero se
entiende este es un n menos 1 y este es
otro bien a menos uno en el ine en el -1
viene y cuál es el determinante de esta
matriz pues esto es igual a 11 x a 22 x
todas estas cosas que escribimos por acá
y todos los que no escribimos por la n 2
n menos 2 por y aquí volvemos a sacar el
determinante de una matriz de 2 por 2
que es triangular superior entonces como
vimos al inicio este vídeo el
determinante esta matriz es simplemente
an1n1 por a nn o lo podemos volver a
sacar aquí es este por este que es justo
es lo que escribió aquí menos este por 0
que 0 o que entonces ya terminamos este
es el determinante de una matriz de en
'por n triangular superior y justo lo
que es es la multiplicación de todas las
entradas de la diagonal principal ok
entonces si tenemos una matriz del
tamaño que sea o sea del tamaño n por n
donde en es cualquier número y esta
matriz además es triangular superior o
sea que todas las entradas abajo de la
diagonal principal son 0
entonces el determinante de esta matriz
lo podemos sacar muy fácilmente
simplemente multiplicando todas las
entradas que están en la diagonal
principal lo cual está súper padre no o
sea porque hemos simplificado muchísimo
la forma de calcular determinantes para
este tipo de matrices no o sea si
tenemos una matriz de cien por cien que
es triangular superior entonces ya nada
más tenemos que multiplicar 100 entradas
en lograr hacer un proceso larguísimo
que seguramente implica hacer más de
10.000 multiplicaciones entonces sólo
para verificar que me hayas entendido
muy bien vamos a sacar un determinante
de una matriz de 4x4
hace mucho que no hago determinantes de
4x4 entonces aquí tenemos por ejemplo 7
y como es una matriz triangular aquí
vamos a tener 3 ceros después por aquí
podemos tener no sé un 5 menos 2 y otra
vez como es una matriz triangular debajo
de la diagonal hay puros ceros
pero bueno no no queremos 0 de este lado
verdad entonces pongámosle un 1 otro uno
nos toca un 0 3
453 ok y entonces si queremos calcular
el determinante de esta matriz lo único
que necesitamos hacer es tomar la
diagonal principal o sea todas estas
entradas y multiplicar las o sea que nos
queda si esta es la matriz
entonces el determinante de la matriz a
es igual a 7 x menos 2 por 1 por 3 y ya
o sea todos los elementos de la diagonal
principal ok y esto es menos dos por
tres
es menos 6 por 7 igual a menos 42
desde hacía cuánto que no me salía tan
rápido un determinante es súper útil
esta técnica no